Herr Lauterbach zurück aus Paris und
herzlich willkommen in Hamburg wann
haben Sie das letzte Mal mit ihrem SPD
Parteikollegen Sebastian Fiedler
gesprochen
äh gestern
und ja immer gute Gespräche genau so
Fachmann man sich gern mit dem ja und
worum ging's da könnte um Cannabis
gegangen sein ja okay und warum hören
Sie nicht auf den wenn das so ein guter
Fachmann ist na ja also zunächst einmal
der Konflikt ist ja hier der es gibt im
Bereich der Innenpolitik Vorbehalte
gegen unsere Cannabis Gesetzgebung und
da ist auch zum Teil die Position in der
SPD nicht einseit nicht eindeutig zum
Teil ist gut also die härtesten
Widersacher gegen dieses Gesetz kommen
aus ihrer eigenen Partei ab würde ich
nicht sagen die Herzen Widersacher sind
da bei der Union oder gar bei den
nichtdemokraten also die Ampel das ist
ja die Opposition genau von der
Regierung von der sie ja noch teil ja ja
in der Regierung in also in der
Regierung gibt es da so ein paar
Vorbehalte in der SPD auch in der SPD ja
das ja das gehört aber zum Geschäft dazu
in dem Sinne wir diskutieren in der
Sache und ich glaube das bringt uns auch
weiter wir haben jetzt z.Bp dieses
Gesetz noch mal ein bisschen verändert
dass wir die Belange der Innenpolitiker
aufgenommen haben indem wir bereits nach
2 Jahren das Gesetz noch einmal
evaluieren auch unter Beteiligung des
bkas daran bin ja auch ich interessiert
dass das geset sich gut umsetzen lässt
einmal ganz kurz damit s es mal
verstehen ich weiß nicht wie sehr Frau
Aman da im im Thema ist
m was was kommt da genau also am 19
Februar soll das verabschiedet werden im
Bundestag in der Woche 19 ja das also
kan genau das wäre der Plan 19 20 so was
darf dann wer und wie viel ab dem 14
wäre dann also kannabis erlaubt das wäre
legal für der eigenen Konsum der eigenen
Besitz man kann dann also 25 g Cannabis
bis zu 25 g cannabis kann man am Mann
tragen man darf in der Öffentlichkeit
auch rauchen konsumieren allerdings
nicht in der Nähe von Kindertagesstätten
oder Schulen so dass der Kinder und
Jugendschutz also gewährlastet ist und
man kann ab dem 1.7 dann in Cannabis
Clubs die Cannabis anbauen für den
Eigenbedarf kann man Cannabis beziehen
das hat zwei also Konsequenzen zwei
Ziele sind hier im Vordergrund zum einen
diejenigen die schon konsumieren die
sind dann nicht mehr auf den
Schwarzmarkt angewiesen auch nicht mehr
auf die Dealer nicht mehr auf die
Kriminalität auf die Beimengungen
toxische Konzentrationen das heißt wir
erkennen an dass Cannabis in der
Gesellschaft konsumiert wird und zum
zweiten wir wollen aber durch einen
verstärkten Kinder und Jugendschutz und
durch die Betonung dass es eben eine
Droge ist die gerade das wachsende
Gehirn beschädigen kann und wir Kinder
und Jugendliche indem wir das
enttabuisieren besser schützen ähm mal
zwei Sätze von Sebastian Fiedler äh
einem Gesetz das zu einer
Entkriminalisierung von Dealern und
sinnloser Mehrarbeit für die Polizei
führt kann ich nicht zustimmen die
organisierte Kriminalität lacht sich ins
Fäustchen mein Berufsethos als
Kriminalbeamter lässt da für mich nichts
anderes zu ja ich kritisiere hier nicht
Sebastian Fedler das ist ein sehr also
anerkannter Kollege mit dem ich übrigens
sehr lange im Bereich also Drogen äh
Kriminalität brauch ich im Moment nicht
kriegen sie ich damit die Leute
verstehen was die Kritik ist nur fürs
ganze ne aber ich möchte einen Satz
korrigieren weil Sebastian Fiedler ist
also in einem Punkt hier wahrscheinlich
falsch zitiert worden wir
entkriminalisieren ja nicht den Handel
sondern Handel sogar Weitergabe sogar
verschenken bleibt illegal das heißt
wenn ich jetzt konsumiere und habe Stoff
und würde Frau amn etwas abgeen bei
einer Party wo auch immer das wäre
weiterhin illegal gesch kontert denn
Kontrolle ist etwas anderes aber sind
gerade gerade sebastianler fsch zitiert
worden so zitiert worden als wenn wir
legalisieren würden dass man abgeben
kann oder handeln kann das ist nicht der
Fall jeder abgabeantritte jeder Handel
bleibt bestrafen sind die Strafen sogar
verschärft worden wenn ein Erwachsener
über 21 an Jugendliche abgibt ist die
mindest
bis zu ist die Mindeststrafe 2 Jahre
also wenn ich systematisch an
Jugendlicher abgebe bin über 21 Z Jahre
Mindeststrafe über jugliche reden wir
gleich noau aber nur das nicht der
falsche Eindruck die Strafen für das
Handeln sind verschärft worden ist nicht
also legalisiert worden we es war gerade
falsch zitiert ne der Satz ist so schon
richtig und ich glaube Sebastian Fedler
als ein Mann aus der Praxis sagt einfach
was das in der in der Realität bedeutet
schlicht undtergreifend ist doch
weltfremd zu sagen ich gebe Frau Armann
auf einer Party joint ab und Wehe we
wenn ich dabei erwischt wirst wer soll
das denn kontrollieren der
Kontrollaufwand der ist ja jetzt auch da
wir haben jetzt wird ja so getan als
wenn jetzt nicht kontrolliert würde wir
kontrollieren jetzt immer weiter und
fassen die kleinaler wir kommen an die
großen nicht dran wir kriminalisieren
junge Leute die dann dann Eintrag also
ins Bundeszentralregister haben
180.000 Verfahren pro Jahr wir haben
also bisher eine mega also Kontrolle wir
haben viele Verurteilungen der Umsatz
steigt Jahr für Jahr Kinder und
Jugendliche konsumieren mehr und junge
erwachsen auch das heißt das System
jetzt ist komplett gescheitert jetzt
kann ich den Kopf in den Sand stecken
und sage ich tue so als wenn derzeit
kein Problem da wäre oder ich versuche
das Problem zu lösen und das ist die
Aufgabe die ich habe das so zu lösen
dass Kinder und Jugendliche besser
geschützt werden dass es aber nicht zu
diesen 1000 Verurteilungen kommt wo es
im Prinzip um kansskonsum geht zweiter
Satz künftig darf ein Dealer mit Stoff
für
75 joints ganz legal rumlaufen so viel
kann man nämlich aus 25 g Cannabis
gewinnen sagt Sebastian Fiedler selbst
in den Niederlanden sind nur 5 g erlaubt
und er sagt er braucht für sich selbst
wenn er erwischt wird ja 75 ja und wenn
er erwischt wird sagt er das ist mein
Eigenverbrauch natürlich aber doch
nichts vor der Dealer den der uns
interessiert den wir wirklich also
derzeit auch verfolgen also mein
Wahlkreis ist Köln Köln Mühlheim
kolbstraße einer der größten
umschlagsplätze für also Drogen in ganz
Deutschland muss man sagen also dieses
Umfeld der Dealer der uns interessiert
das ist doch nicht der kleine FIS der 25
g am Mann trägt wenn der dann sagt sind
75 jointschuigung ja aber wir sprechen
ja hier über Kilo
bis Tonnen in dem Sinne das sind ja die
und da werden wir also jetzt die
Ermittlungen fokussieren wir haben doch
bei der also Fokussierung auf die klein
Kriminalität haben wir keinen Erfolg
gehabt die Wahrheit ist doch der Konsum
nimmt zu wir haben Verunreinigungen wir
haben einen Schwarzmarkt der also
komplett außer Kontrolle ist und wir
haben was ganz wichtig ist Zunahme bei
Kindern und Jugendlichen weil die Dealer
sich genau auf diese so also
Kundengruppe konzentrieren da müssen wir
doch reagieren und den Schwarzmarkt dort
auszutrocknen ist eine wichtige Maßnahme
Lauterbach ganz kurz darf ich einmal sie
sagen jetzt als Jugendschutz dass sie
bannmeilen um Schulen Kindergärten
Spielplätze von 100 m drumhum
installieren damit ist der Jugendschutz
doch aber noch nicht zu Ende also damit
ist nicht genug der hauptjugendschutz
den wir machen werden wir werden was ja
derzeit ein Tabu Thema ist wird nicht
viel drüber gesprochen aber wir werden
durch Kampagnen ganz klar machen was ja
die Neuigkeit für viele Jugendliche auch
ist und auch für viele Eltern ist das
wachsende Gehirn nimmt dauerhaften
Schaden vom Cannabiskonsum aber warum
legalisieren sie es dann ab 18 sie
wissen doch als Arzt auch ganz genau
dass mit 18 die hirnreife nicht
abgeschlossen ist ist ja das was wir als
erztinnen gefordert haben auch die
Kinder und jugendpsychiaterinnen haben
ja sehr klar sich positioniert das
legalisierungsalter 18 ist viel zu frü
genau wird vorgeschlagen man soll mit 25
legalisieren aber das hätte das Problem
hätte weil das die Situation
verschlechtert hätte dann wäre der Markt
für der Schwarzmarkt mit den hohen
Konzentrationen mit den Beimengungen der
wäre dann für die unter 25-Jährigen
geblieben und wir hätten nur die Eltern
wo das Gehirn ausgewachsen ist besser
geschüzt aber verschwindet ja jetzt
nicht der Markt verschwindet ja nicht
weil nach wie vor Leute interessiert
sein daran sein werden den Stoff zu
kaufen ihn vielleicht nicht selber
anbauen möchten und jetzt können sie
auch noch noch Leute treffen die wenn
sie erwischt werden mit mit joints auch
noch dann legal davon kommen also man
hat den Eindruck sie haben den Kopf aus
dem Sand genommen und haben ihn dann ein
Meter weiter wieder reingesteckt weil
die metap mit dem Modell funktioniert do
nicht B ne die Metapher passt nicht
zunächst einmal ich habe mich da
wirklich sehr intensiv auch mit der
Studienlage beschäftigt was passiert
wenn man es macht und die Länder wo man
das am besten ausgewerertet hat das ist
der Bundesstaat Colorado der hat sehr
genau ausgewertet was passiert wenn man
legalisiert und und Kanada das sind
Modelle die kann man ungefähr
vergleichen funktionieren ein bisschen
anders und in Kanada ist durch die
Legalisierung der Schwarzmarkt um zwei
Drittel kleiner geworden es gibt also
weniger Kriminelle die versuchen ihre
Kinder und meine Kinder abhängig zu
machen weniger Schwarzmarkt und es ist
z.B in kolorado so verkauft od wird er
verkauft oder wird ist dann nur
eigenanau Problem wird ja nicht kleiner
ne das Problem ist dort z.B wo wir es
beobachten konnen in Colorado ist der
Anstieg bei den jungen Menschen die
konsumieren gebremst worden und sogar
leicht zurückgegangen in anderen
Bundesstaaten nimmen das zu wir nehmen
doch an wenn wir jetzt die Bevölkerung
breit darüber aufklären z.B auch bei bei
Sendungen wie jetzt dass Cannabiskonsum
unter 25 dauerhaft das Gehirn
beschädigen kann aber sie Erlau Herr
Lauterbach sie erlauben es aber es ist
doch jetzt da es ist doch jetzt da es
wird dann weniger do etwas bitte sie
sind der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ich ich schaue
ihn in die Augen und vermute bei Ihnen
maximale Kompetenz und das tue ich
zurecht ich sehe diese Sendung und sehe
okay da sitzt der
Bundesgesundheitsminister ist K
Lauterbach ein Mann von der Regierung
das kann kein schlechter Mensch sein der
zwei Doktortitel der kennt sich aus und
der sagt kiffen ab 18 ist jetzt okay ne
ich sag nicht dass es okay ist ich sage
dass sag okay ich sage das ich sage es
ist il legal aber ich rate jedem ab wir
machen ja große Kampagne aber wir müssen
uns doch ehrlich machen der Konsum
sollen wir so lassen wir jetzt der
Konsum steigt die Konzentrationen werden
immer höher es gibt
Beimengungen jetzt wird Cannabis genutzt
um so schnell wie möglich die abhängigen
in einer Abhängigkeit auch von anderen
Substanzen zusätzlich zu machen die
jetzige Politik hat nicht geklappt ist
gescheitert ist ein riesen Problem und
wenn ich dem begegnen will dann muss ich
aufklären wie gefährlich cannabis ist
und für diejenigen die dann trotzdem
wissend wie gefährlich es ist
konsumieren dass ich dann
zum wo sie Recht haben wo sie Recht
haben ist Cannabiskonsum ist eine
gesellschaftliche Realität und ich nimm
zu das stimmt und ich finde es richtig
dass eine Regierung drüber nachdenkt
wenn offensichtlich die
Kriminalisierung einer Droge nicht den
Effekt hat dass die Leute weniger
konsumieren dann muss man an dieses
System ran aber was ich nicht verstehe
an ihrer Reform ist sie senden dann an
Leute das Signal es ist legal und
zugleich es ist aber soll trotzdem
gerade bei Jugend
Diemen ist unerwüncht und es ist für
euch gefährlich und diesen und und
zugleich limitieren sie das ist der eine
Widerspruch und der zweite Widerspruch
ist sie sie lassen die Leute nur anbauen
also das heißt Sie dürfen es nicht
kaufen ein legales Produkt sozusagen
darf nicht gekauft werden und und das
ist es wird aber trotzdem natürlich dazu
kommen dass die Leute keine Lust haben
das Zeug zu Hause anzubauen sondern sie
wollen es kaufen das heißt sie werden
nach wie vor illegale Strukturen haben
wo diese Substanz verkauft wird ich
halte es für völlig weltfremd zu sagen
dass dass dadurch der Handel
verschwindet weil sich Leute spontan
Ecken W bevor zwei Kritikpunkte würde
ich gerne was zu sagen ganz kurz und
dann gerne der nächste Kritikpunkt der
erste Kritikpunkt ist der erste
Kritikpunkt ist wenn man es so macht
dann geht das mit dem Konsum weiter nach
oben also das ändert nichts das hat sich
eben in den Studien nicht gezeigt das
hat sich in Colorado und auch in Kanada
gezeigt wenn man legalisiert und klärt
gleichzeitig über die Gefahren auf dann
nimmt der Konsum eben nicht zu sondern
bleibt flach oder kurze Verständnisfrage
dazu nimmt dort ist also der ist dort
auch der Handel unzulässig oder wird nur
Eigenanbau auch betrieben so wie in
unserem Modell der Handel ist bei uns
nicht möglich und dort ist das legale
Angebot möglich aber auch nur wirkauft
mit anderen Worten es es schon ein
anderes System als bei uns ich weiß
nicht ob sie automatisch von diesem
System auf ihres schießen K glaub ich
schon also wenn wir den Bedarf damit
decken könen dann also wird der
Schwarzmarkt zurückdringen aber wir
müssen auch überlegen also ich arbeite
ja im Rahmen der eurechtlichen
Möglichkeiten und dieses System was wir
jetzt gemacht haben ist ja wenn man so
will ein
genossenschaftssystem dieses System wird
den Bedarf abdecken können die werden
zum Selbstkostenpreis werden die das
gibt ja überall schon Anmeldungen werden
das anbieten
können Lauterbach wir reden immer über
Drogen hier
geradeürlich Spießer will ich gar nicht
aber ich ich ich ich das ist doch eine
verlugung Genossenschaft ist alles
entspannend und nee das ist nicht
entspannend ich sage ja ich bin
derjenige der das Thema cannabis ist
gefährlich für jeden der unter 25
konsumiert dauerhafte Hirnschäden und so
weiter ich entspanne hier gar nichts
aber ich nehme ich nehme zur Kenntnis
dass jetzt der gefährliche Konsum
ständig zunimmt wenn ich mich jetzt zum
Thema nicht verhalte dann habe ich kein
Problem D muss ich nichts erklären aber
es läuft trotzdem vor die Wand Frau Br
ist also wie bringen sie das
zusammen sie machen Werbung bei sie
Posten bei Instagram als Bundesregierung
buberz wird legal sie bedienen sich der
Jugendsprache um ihren Gesetzesentwurf
unters Volk zu bringen und gleichzeitig
sagen sie
dass ich
legalisere also meine Tochter 18 Jahre
sagt als sie gehört hat okay es geht um
Cannabis ach so das ja da bedienen die
sich doch sogar der Jugendsprache um das
publik zu machen Herr Lindner hat das so
kommuniziert und das ist das ist für
mich der falsche Adressat sie sagen doch
selber es ist eine Werbekampagne auf
Instagram mit
mit in dieser W ganzz in das keine
werbekomp das ist sie hat es auf dem
Handy aber ich will ich will so ich will
so we das darf man so nicht stehen
lassen we es wden falschen völlig
falschen in dieser Kampagne wird vor den
Gefahren von Cannabis gewarnt das ist
der einzige hintergrund der
Kampagne n ganz aber ich
will steh drüberberal also das ist jetzt
nicht sehrend darf ich ja jetzt nicht so
stehen lassen weil wenn jetzt sofort
weiter geredet bleibt stehen wir würden
werben für kanabis das machen wir nicht
wir wir werben gar nicht sondern wir
klären in der Jugendsprache bubatz auf
bubatz beschädigt dein Gehirn das ist
ein Unterschied und somit
erreich steht oben drüber steht oben
drüber es wird legal wird legal das
steht oben drüber handpflanze drunter
buberz wird legal drüber und das ist
das
gehir
aber neinin es gibt nur also Werbung für
Cannabis bleibt illegal wird auch nicht
mit dem Gesetz ermöglich bleibt illegal
jede Werbung ist verboten Werbung ist
jetzt ein anderes Wort Werbung bleibt
verboten aber das ist eine
ausschließliche Aufklärungskampagne über
die Gefahren von Cannabis und zwar in
jeder Einzel such uns gerade jetzt bin
sehr gespannt was GLE ges Krien also das
dann ist es schlecht gemacht weil das
was hängen bleibt bei den Jugendlichen
ist halt dieses Bild was sie da drin
haben und das andere ist sie sagen doch
aber auch ne was haben sie jetzt sie
haben eine Sonderregelung für die 18 bis
21-Jährigen das ist glaube ich der
Kompromiss den sie jetzt geschaffen
haben dass sie den den legalen Besitz da
etwas reduzieren und auch den den
Cannabis die Konzentration vom THC von
reduzieren für diese eher vulnerable
Altersgruppe und trotzdem ist das das so
ihr Fraktionskollege hat 75 joints
ausgerechnet bei 30 g die man im Monat
konsumieren kann waren das nach meiner
Rechnung 90 joints für eine 18 bis
21-Jährige das wären für meine Tochter
drei joints am Tag und da sage ich Ihnen
nicht nur als Mutter sondern auch als
Ärztin bitte nicht ja das ähm die können
das zum Teil nicht abschätzen was das
maum machen sie das so hoch her
lauterbach mal das erkl Sekunde aber
will nur das klar mit jeder einzelnen
Aufklärungskampagne die wir mit
Jugendlichen testen also das ist nicht
so dass der Minister sich da denkt so
könnte das Wirken od so sondern wir
testen das mit Jugendlichen bringen wir
rüber es schädigt euer Gehirn und das
ist auch ethigch nicht anders also kann
es nicht gemacht werden zum zweiten wenn
wir jetzt hier mit Mengen arbeiten
würden die also tatsächlich den Bedarf
bei den viel Konsumenten nicht decken
dann bleibt der Schwarzmarkt das kann
ich auch machen dann hab ich mal ganz
kurz da sind wir gerade bubatz wird
legal und unten drunter
Bundesregierung sorry sie hätten ja
drunter rüber schreiben können Buber
schädigt ihr Gehirn steht aber nicht das
ist ehrlich gesagt nicht die Kampagne
die wir gemacht haben da steht
Bundesregierung drunter das muss geprüft
werden ob das so stimmt aber wir haben
eine Kampagne gemacht die also mit der
Hand also Pflanze gesehen das ist nicht
von Ihnen hier das kann ich zunächst
einmal nicht bewerten ob das von uns ist
aber auf jeden Fall die Kampagne die wir
machen ist Kampagne wo je bei jedes Mal
steht legal aber z.B legal aber
schädlich oder also legal aber
zurückgeblieben und zwar wir erklären in
der Jugendsprache durch unsere Kampagne
auf dass die also dass der Konsum
gefährlich ist kurz fragen Kollegen in
der Regie woher kommt das ist das auf
der einer offiziellen Seite der
Bundesregierung höre gerade ja es wurde
e nicht un verbreitet auf Instagram also
es ist W W nur das ist von der Seite an
der Seite der Bundesregierung also steht
Bundesregierung normalerweise ist ja das
ich kann jetzt nur für unser
Bundesgesundheitsministerium sprechen
dass die Kampagne die wir
machenelle Account der Bundesregierung
hö ich gerade ja offiziell muss ich
prüfen aber ich kann jetzt nur für
unsere kampüssen sie nicht haben wir
schon für Sie gemacht ja alles gut aber
ich kann jetzt nur für die Kampagne
sprechen die ich selbst verantworte als
Bundesgesundheitsminister und wir haben
eine Kampagne gemacht die sich an junge
Leute wendet wo wir ganz genau
beschreiben in der Kampagne es ist legal
aber schädlich aber ist das nicht auch
das Problem also wenn ich jetzt an meine
nicht gerade wilde Jugend zurückdenke an
meine Schulzeit es wurde ständig überall
gekifft und ähm ich habe immer mal
wieder probiert aber immer mit diesem
Gedanken oh das ist eine illegale Droge
es ist eine Droge ich darf das
eigentlich nicht nicht nur meine Eltern
wollen das nicht damit hätte ich noch
gut leben können aber es ist sozusagen
was verbotenes und ich denke schon es
macht was mit Leuten ob die wenn die die
Botschaft haben es ist legal dann dann
kann man doch nicht gleichzeitig die
widersprüchliche Botschaft setzen es ist
aber gefährlich es ist legal ihr dürft's
machen aber es ist gefährlich und das
ist so eine Verwirrung die damit hat
sich was verändert und wenn ich noch
eine Frage stellen darf nur we ich
möchte nur noch eine Frage stellen sie
haben ja diese Regel eingeführt die
vermeintlich Sicherheit schaffen soll
das z.B nicht in der Nähe von Schulen
konsumiert werden nicht in der Nähe von
das gleich noch mal extra behandeln weil
total wichtiger aber nur die Frage ist
es nicht weltfremd über 18jährige
begegnen doch ständig Leuten unter 18 es
durchmischt sich irgendwie die Kids
spielen mit oder verbring Zeit mit mit
Leuten die älter sind und die vielleicht
die das legal besitzen dürfen und dass
das dann da nicht probiert wird oder
geteilt wird oder weitergegeben wird ist
doch ehrlich gesagt völlig weltfrem
genau jetzt zur ersten Frage was sich es
hat sich ja was verändert in unserer
Gesellschaft das das Kiffen illegal ist
das interessiert heute bei den jungen
Leuten so gut wie niemanden mehr sie
machen es trotzdem früher als sie jung
gewesen sind ma das noch eine Rolle
gespielt haben so lange her ja ist jetzt
also vor kurzem also kürzlich war aber
es interessiert heute keinen mehr
sondern Tatsache ist die jungen Leute
kifffen es wird immer mehr das heißt die
Frage ist überlasse ich diese jungen
Leute schlicht und ergifen dem
Schwarzmarkt mit extrem hohen
Konzentrationen mit Beimengungen und mit
kriminellen Dealern die versuchen ich
will das beantworten dürfen bitte
nicht und da das jetzt so ist dass sich
das jetzt geändert hat ist jetzt die
Strategie die in Kanada und in auch
wirkt dass ich sage das ist jetzt nicht
mehr illegal aber es ist schädlich somit
es dass es schädlich ist H das bringt
noch mal Musik da rein dass es illegal
ist das hol das da kätt kein han mehr
nach wir mussten umstellen Illegalität
schützt nicht mehr aber Aufklärung es
schadet eurem Gehirn das wird Schütz
aber Rückfrage dazu sie sagen es wird
auch die Leute werden geschützt vor
gefährlichen Beimischungen es ist viel
sauberer und so weiter sie wissen doch
gar nicht wie die das Anbauen sie wissen
doch gar nicht was da was da oder sie
jetzt Dealer der die H g Lauterbach
einmal Malin Argument der Dealer der das
den Stoff mit dem höheren THC anbietet
der verschwindet deswegen doch nicht
aber glau wir ernsthaft dass derjenige
da auf der Suche nach mehr Knall und
bums ist wir sehen es doch in Kanada es
geht doch zurück und das do logisch W
dort wir der Verkauf wurde dort
legalisiert wenn ich jetzt richtig
verstanden hab und das ist ja bei uns
gerade nicht so ne man kann nicht man h
ist ja auch ein Widerspruch der
Widerspruch ist einerseits heißt es na
ja das wird den Schwarzmarkt nicht
zurückdräen denn da wird so viel
nachgefragt das reicht gar nicht das
schaffen die gar nicht auf der anderen
Seite wird umgekehrt argumentiert auf 50
g viel zu viel und so das passt schon
wir werden wir haben das gemacht dass
viel zur Verfügung steht aber nicht zu
viel das ist mit Augen was gemacht und
da wird es so sein dass wir den
Schwarzmarkt richtig zurücktrhen können
und tatsächlich wer ist denn so blöd und
geht jetzt für auf den girly und holt
sich dort ein giftiges Produkt mit
beimächung von je jemanden der einem
verkauft mein Verkauf noch ausrauben
kann wenn ich gleichzeitig legal in der
Genossenschaft abholen kann ist es
billiger und ist sicher das macht doch
dann niemand mehr oder viel weniger
Leute werden das mal und das ist der
Grund weshalb das tatsächlich dort wo es
geht den Schwarzmarkt zurückgedrängt hat
wie sehen Sie das drei Ärzte heute hier
am Bord wenn man karluterbach auch dazu
zählt kann man mehr medizinische
Kompetenz war noch nie in einer Sendung
wie sehen Sie das ja also es ist
natürlich nicht mein Spezialthema das
ist klar ich bin Radiologe
genau als solcher würde ich sagen wir
sind uns ja überhaupt wir sind uns ja
alle einig dass je weniger desto besser
für Cannabis gilt natürlich also es gibt
medizinische Alkohol ne das ist genau
der Punkt ich finde diese Debatte
ehrlicherweise total scheinheilig denn
in meiner klinischen Praxis als
Radiologe habe ich sehr sehr viele
Menschen gesehen die durch Suchtmittel
seh große Schäden erlitten haben und
diese Suchtmittel waren fast immer
Alkohol und Zigaretten
ja und das ist ein das ist ein immenser
Schaden der dadurch ausgelöst wird und
man sieht das als Radiologe wenn ich
jetzt wenn ich jetzt ein CT mir angucke
dann kann ich i nach 3 Sekunden sagen ob
sie Raucher sind oder ob sie zu viel
trinken ich bin ich völlig bei Ihnen nur
das Argument zu sag nur weil alle sauf s
jetzt auch alle kiffen ist kein sor nur
es halt es dann sollten wir doch lieber
den die große Kampagne machen und sagen
Alkohol ist komplett ungesund und lass
es bleiben statt zu sagen kiffen ist
jetzt erlaubt aber soll denn mehr
gekifft werden ist das der Wunsch dann
lassen wir alles wie es ist dann lassen
es weiter wachsen dann lassen wir
einfach dann lassen wir es Wachstum zu
den Igal dann überlassen wir den Markt
komplett im Schwarzmarkt wir sagen geht
da rein geht auf die jungen Leute zu
verkauft euer dreckiges Zeug macht
Beimengungen geht mit der mit der die
zum Teil wird jetzt mit so hohen so also
Prozentzahlen THC gearbeitet dass man
sehr schnellsüchtig wird dann lassen wir
die jungen Leute dem Schwarzmarkt und
sagen geht da rein mach das Wesen dass
das illegal ist das war es heute jemand
das hält niemanden mehr ab das hält
niemanden mehr ab das heißt jetzt kann
es nur noch darum gehen dass wir sag
nicht ob das so uneingeschränkt für
Minderjährige gilt also das sagen Sie
jetzt sozusagen aber das wissen wir das
haben sie dazu eine Studio in Bayern
beispielsweise 27% der 18 bis 24
Jährigen kiffen haben sie sich den me
73% es nicht tun also das wäre so der
Jugendschutz den ich mir wünschen würde
zuck wo sind denn die resilienzfaktoren
bei den den meisten Jugendlichen die es
ja halt eben trotzdem nicht tun ja alles
gut das tun wir natürlich alles aber ich
muss das Problem lösen dass wir derzeit
eine Situation haben wo uns der
Drogenkonsum bei jungen Leuten aus der
Kontrolle gerätt und da kann ich sagen
mein Name ist Hase ich mache nichts oder
ich versuche auf der Grundlage der
Studienlage das zu probieren und wir
werden ja nach Z Jahren aus ich bekomme
jeden Tag besser wisserische Vorschläge
aber keine vorsch läge praktisch was man
denn stattdessen machen sollte und das
hier hat funktioniert in Colorado und in
Kanada hat's funktioniert meine eigene
Tochter hat im vorletzten Jahr ein
ganzes Jahr da gelebt ich kenne die Lage
da ganz gut und das sollten wir aus
meiner Sicht da sollten wir uns ehrlich
machen den Konsum weiter zu verbieten es
hat einfach nicht geklappt aber eine
Frage mal politische Art wenn jetzt in
zwei Jahren die Evaluation ergibt hat
nicht geklappt ist es realistisch dass
dann gesagt wird wir nehmen wieder auf
die Liste der illegalen Substanzen ist
ja ehrlich gesagt komplett unrealistisch
oder und es ist ja schon faszinierend
dass sie es geschafft haben dass die
Ampel sich einigen konnte auf ein
Projekt und ihre eigenen Innenpolitiker
sind dagegen also ich meine das ist
wirklich glaube ich in der kurzen
geschichteind alle in sind die
wichtigsten drei die sind nicht alle
Innenpolitiker dagegen und werden D
nachher die Abstimmung dann sehen ich
nehme die Kritik der Innenpolitiker sehr
ernst also das ist gar keine Frage ich
habe auch auch sehr gute Kontakte zu
Ermittlern also ich hat eben schon
gesagt kölnmülheim kolbstraße was also
auf der Straße passiert ist mir nicht
fremd von daher nehme ich das alles sehr
ernst aber in Erwägung all dieser Punkte
sind wir trotzdem zu dem Ergebnis
gekommen auch die Stu die die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden für den
Innenbereich also stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende für Innenbereich
der hat zum Schluss zugestimmt somit
werden wir das Gesetz machen aber es ist
ein Gesetz was Überzeugungsarbeit
benötigte und dafür also muss man halt
Ringen das kommt nicht von allein ich
hab noch zwei zwei technische Fragen
noch ganz kurz 25 g sozusagen darf man
mit sich führen das heißt die Polizei
ist dann unterwegs mit einer Waage und
misst das dann genau oder wie wie läuft
das ja jetzt wird ja auch wenn sie
erwicht werden wird ja auch geprüft wie
viel das da ist und so weiter und so
fort und da kommt es nicht auf einen
Gram an ich habe eben schon mal gesagt
die Leute die uns interessiert die
Dealer die jetzt das große Geschäft
machen die das sind nicht die Leute die
mit 25 g rum Frage
Jugendschutz im im Umfeld von Schulen
wie weit müssen diese Leute die das
dabei haben von Schulen weg sein künftig
100 m die anbauvereine 200 m und
diejenigen die konsumieren also in
brauchen 100 m genau 100 m und würden
Sie sagen dass im Jahre 2024 junge
Menschen in der Lage sind 100 m zu
überwinden das hoffe ich sehr das hoffe
ich das doch also machen wir uns doch
nichts vor ich kann hier zulassen dass
also man vor der äh also Kita steht und
das Zeug konsumiert oder ich also habe
hier eine Grenze und es gibt sehr viele
Regeln die wir haben Abstandsregeln äh
die also sporadisch kontrolliert werden
aber äh ganz also auf eine solche Regel
zu verzichten wäre Unsinn dann würde ich
ja erlauben dass vor der Schule vor der
Kit vielleicht auf dem Schulhof sogar
konsumiert werden kann das kann nicht
richtig sein jetzt kann ich sagen das
müssen 3 km sein das wäre absurd 100 m
ist etwas was also komm mal großen Pause
relativ zu pragmatisch gesprochen ist
das etwas damit kann man aus meiner
Sicht Arbeiten hab wir lange drüber
gearbeit D können die anderen auch
arbeiten